los más de 6.000 nuevos casos de
coronavirus registrados en alemania en
las últimas 24 horas no solamente
representan un récord del número más
alto registrado en este país desde que
comenzó la pandemia sino que también se
ha convertido en un reto muy importante
para las autoridades que están teniendo
serias dificultades para ponerse de
acuerdo sobre las medidas que deben
tomarse en alemania no solo en la
actualidad sino también de cara a los
próximos meses de otoño y de invierno
considerados particularmente importantes
para afrontar la actual crisis de
coronavirus el miércoles la canciller
alemana angela merkel y los 16 líderes
regionales estuvieron reunidos en la
cancillería alemana aquí en berlín
durante más de 8 horas para tratar de
acordar medidas enfocadas principalmente
en las grandes ciudades donde se están
concentrando los contagios y que se ha
convertido también en la principal razón
de preocupación de las autoridades de iu
que la canciller alemana y los líderes
de las diferentes regiones hayan
acordado que en las zonas consideradas
de alto riesgo se amplíe el uso del
tapabocas
los lugares públicos se reduzca el
número de personas que pueden reunirse y
se cierren también bares y restaurantes
a partir de las 11 de la noche son
medidas muy controversiales para algunos
medidas muy positivas para tratar de
controlar la pandemia principalmente en
las grandes ciudades pero para otros no
van lo suficientemente lejos en
particular de cara al gran reto que
afrontan alemania y europa en los
próximos meses